[Music]
all right if you watch the show
regularly you do know that I'm not only
a student of the martial arts it's a
passion of mine there's no more Elite
venue for mixed martial arts in the
world than the UFC and of course it's
iconic octagon and there must watch
events but tonight breaking news from
outside the arena where UFC president
Dana White he just announced that Bud
Light yes the budlight will become the
official beer partner of the league now
after veering all of course which I
thought was stupid into the you know wo
cultural wars in the country uh is this
a strong message from anheiser Bush and
Bud Light that uh we've heard you loud
and clear and we're getting back on
track anyway here with more on all this
this brand new partnership as UFC
president CEO Dana White is with us you
know so I had you on my radio show today
been on radio 30 plus years been here
I'm in my 28th year at Fox and you know
what's interesting to me is I refuse to
call for boycotts firings cancellations
any of this stuff I'm against all of it
I didn't like I thought it was stupid of
of Budweiser or budlight to get into
that controversy just dumb and I have no
idea why they waited into those wats but
my fear from the beginning was not the
person that made the dumb decision or
the people that made the dumb decision
when I saw this taken hold I was
concerned about the people that work for
budlight those are high-paying career
jobs and I said that publicly and I'm
hoping you know everybody knows who you
are Dana No Holds Barred kick ass take
no prisoners I don't give an Adam shift
you you're in anybody's face so they
purposely went with you tell us about
it yeah you know well first of all let
me start with uh you know they they were
the first beer company that we really
did business with they're our first real
big sponsor uh when we were getting
started and now we're back with them and
going into this deal you know I I know
all the controversy and everything else
but for myself going into a long-term
deal with another sponsor I want to be
with somebody that I'm actually aligned
with and I know people were were upset
with what they did but uh I'm looking at
all the good things that they do you
know they they employ 65,000 Americans
they have thousands of vets that work
for them they spend $700 million a year
with us Farmers using their crops to
make their products and many many other
great things that anheiser bush has done
uh in this country and those are the
things that I'm focused on uh when I
look at a long-term sponsor that's going
to be we're we're going to do a six-year
deal here I want to be with somebody
that I'm aligned with all those things
that I just mentioned to you are what
I'm all about and not to mention they
they have this thing called folds VOR
I'm very big into law enforcement and
Military and over the last I don't know
how many years they've spent like $45
million taking care of uh you know these
servicemen and First Responders who have
died taking care of their families
scholarships for their kids and things
like that so I am very aligned with
anheiser bush all right let me be clear
about a few things um there were other
beer companies that wanted to to partner
with you correct um you certainly I know
you don't need the money because you
have more money than anyone could ever
want and probably for thousand lifetimes
so you didn't do it for the money you
didn't do it you know you you did it for
the reason stated but you also knew and
it's already happening on social media
that you'd be attacked you'd be accused
of selling out I want you to respond to
those
people well let's be clear when you do
sponsorships you definitely do
sponsorships for the money too um money
is definitely a part of it but money was
not the decision making uh you know it
wasn't the reason that I made the
decision all the things that I just told
you are why I mean there's more um to
being aligned with a sponsor a major
sponsor like that for as long as I'm
going to be um you know there are many
other things that are important to me
other than just the money and the people
that were all involved in this
negotiation on every side absolutely
positively know that my choice was not
determined by
money yeah I know that you know one of
the things that I would say is you know
when you factor in what you said about
their support of the military when you
factor in that they support us Farmers
uh when you you factor in for me the
most important things I I knew it and it
did happen I knew great people that work
for Budweiser once those the beer sales
slip dramatically because it was a
strong message that what the hell are
you doing why are you diving into these
cultural Wars it was stupid um sorry
sorry you at that time your partner your
new partner was being stupid they should
never have gotten into the political
Arena like that um but I do think and I
hope this and I'm a Christian I believe
in second chances forgiveness right I'm
hoping that maybe for the sake of the
people that need their career jobs back
to pay their mortgages car payments rent
and and need those career jobs and get
their health insurance back that maybe
people might consider giving them
another chance with the clear
understanding if they screw up again
like this they're never coming back and
you might be the guy that's able to
bridge that Gap maybe to give this
company another chance and maybe give
another look at it and I I I know how
much you offered from other companies it
wasn't about the money um but yeah
everything's about the money but it's
not so I hope for the workers that it
works out for them because they were
innocent victims in this and they're
good people that need those jobs I'll
give you the last
word yeah you know that's what I say too
and and it's about uh listen like I said
before they run their business they do
their thing um they do a lot of great
things they do a lot of great things
they employ 65,000 people in this
country they take care of farmers and
did you know that when there's big
disasters they shut the plant down and
they turn it into a a water bottling
facility and they they bottled like a
100 million uh bottles of water that
they've sent out to disaster areas this
I'm going to focus on the good that they
do we are very aligned in many different
areas and that's why they're going to be
my partner for the next six years look I
admire you knew that you'd get incoming
you did it anyway you have strong
reasons why you did it um I really cared
about then and I care about now the
workers and you know what all these
other things that you brought up that I
also support the military law
enforcement all these things Amazing by
the way why didn't Elon Musk and
Zuckerberg get in the uh octagon
uh you said you talked to both of them
what happened I want to see
that yeah yeah a lot of people want to
see it uh you know I don't know listen I
never say never but yeah I don't know we
we we'll see we'll see we'll see how
this plays out it was all to me it was
all talk Elon get in the get in shape
get in the Octagon Zuckerberg get ready
game on everybody will see it do it for
charity it'll be a great event for
everyone all right Dana it's interesting
uh good luck with the partnership and I
hope those jobs those people are rehired
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else